[Music]
if this low keynote were a musical
its overture would be my first memory of
listening to an overture
i was in first grade at my local high
school's production of rogerson
hammerstein's cinderella
i sat on my knees on an old folding
chair in a dusty gym
temporarily converted into auditorium i
craned my neck to watch the pianist play
every line of that overture trying to
commit it to memory
i was hooked when the fluorescent lights
of that gym flickered off
and the overture started it was like a
religious
experience when i went to see a show i
never
sat back and relaxed for me theater
always meant
leaning in and as i've gotten older
i find myself not only leaning in but
also
looking around to see what the rest of
the audience is thinking
at a broadway show a couple years ago i
remember
looking over the balcony and seeing two
audience members who had entered the
theater appearing to be strangers
reach across the aisle to comfort each
other after a particularly tear-filled
musical number
these memories of being in a theater are
the overture to this low-key note
because it's moments like this that have
made me see theater as a way to develop
empathy if you're interested in becoming
an
empathetic leader and i suspect many of
us here at the gsbr
i invite you to see the stage as a tool
for developing yourself
and your communities so
from this stage today we'll explore
first the function of the arts and
theater especially
and second what the industry and all of
us can do
to democratize access to theater
let's start with function i see theater
as a sort of cheat code for developing
empathy
the best theater asks its audience
members to lean in
and take an imaginative leap into new
stories and new characters
and that happens with an audience around
us you may enter the theater
as an individual but once you're there
you become part of an
audience that laughs together holds its
breath together
you become part of a living collective
response
theater is one of the only communal
experiences we have
with a group that we haven't filtered
out ahead of time
the results can be fantastic and even
physiological as evidenced by research
done by neuroscientists at university
college london
they discovered that watching theater
can synchronize the heartbeats of an
audience
it's an experience so extraordinary that
it can overcome group differences
in just a couple of hours theater can
work double time
to not only entertain but to connect
that's an experience everyone should
have access to
but unfortunately the theater industry
can feel
inaccessible if not exclusive and
elitist
to many one of its challenges is
geographic
theater can be tough to get to much of
theater's creative capital remains
locked up in a small radius in a few
blocks in manhattan
that's a world that felt a million miles
away from where i grew up
in a small town in rural nebraska back
home
i was thankful for that occasional local
production
and i savored any youtube bootleg video
of theater that i could get my hands on
another challenge is financial theater
tickets can be
prohibitively expensive this is a
challenge
i saw firsthand while working with a
broadway theater producer
there i saw how high ticket prices
needed to be
to even give the show a chance at
breaking even each week
but beyond geographic and financial
challenges
there are perceived barriers to access
some wonder whether they even belong in
theaters that may not have represented
or welcomed them before
all of these were challenges to theater
before
pandemic brought the industry to its
knees
yes this is an inflection point for
theater
but it's not the end of theater it's
just an intermission
like many areas in life covet has given
us a chance to reassess
and make some changes going forward
i for one am starting to get optimistic
about where we're headed next
so for the second act of this low
keynote
we'll look to the future to see what the
industry
and all of us can do to democratize
access to theater one of the keys
is how theater will come back in a new
conversation with technology
now here we have to address the elephant
in the room
you and i are not in the same room
together
i feel the tension of talking about my
love of being
in a theater together live while giving
this talk
to a camera alone recorded
one of the many reasons why i love
theater is because it's an antidote to a
life of screens
look i'm a sucker for a live experience
but i'm
also excited about the ways that
technology can amplify some parts of
theater
to make it more accessible technology
can drive
three shifts in distribution development
and discovery of theater
on distribution digitization has the
potential to help
theater reach wider audiences yes
even reach some kid in nebraska for all
of you who devoured hamilton from your
couches this past summer
there's likely more theatrical content
headed your way
producers appear to be shedding the old
conventional wisdom that
putting theater on screen cannibalizes
demand
instead they're recognizing that while
being
inside of a theater is not the same
thing as watching what's happening
inside of a theater the recorded version
can increase viewership and can generate
demand for the live experience
additionally theater will continue to
explore ways to use technology to not
just
share but enhance its storytelling
from ar vr emerging audio platforms and
other innovations
theater makers will find ways to capture
some of the sparks of live theater
in new formats distribution is changing
and so is development the development
process
of a big show from idea to opening is a
long and winding road
it can be a multi-year journey from labs
readings workshops regional productions
festivals and other stops
but digitizing some of the steps of the
development process
can help theater makers develop their
shows more quickly and more affordably
and reach less insular audiences along
the way
there's also a benefit to the
cross-pollination of theatrical
development
putting exciting and diverse local
theater on screen
makes it more accessible and allows it
to influence
more theater makers around the world
finally there's a shift in how we
discover
a combination of improved technology and
a global pandemic
has propelled theater to pop up in more
places and platforms than ever before
including a crowdsourced tik-tok musical
it's an eye-opening reminder that
theater isn't tied to a building
that can help us discover new theatrical
voices
sidestepping some of the gatekeepers
that have traditionally guarded the
industry
from distribution to development to
discovery
technology has the potential to amplify
live arts
and theater is an industry with
creativity coursing through its veins
so i know this is just the start
that's what the industry can do to
democratize access to theater
i'll end with what all of us can do
appreciate the function of the arts and
champion
its importance in your communities that
can mean
seeing more theater each year in any
format and supporting your local
artistic organizations
consider the social return on your
investment in artistic organizations
and once you leave stanford and become
leaders in your own communities
see this stage as a way to develop
yourself and those communities
from this stage today we explored the
function of theater
and what all of us can do to democratize
access to it
and while many stages around the world
remain dark right now
i'm betting that theater's next act will
be its greatest one yet